ja es geht um thüringen die arbeit
beginnt jetzt
ich bitte doch davon abzusehen meine
rede zu unterbricht nicht zeige die höhe
ich zeige den höchst größten respekt vor
der aufgabe und danke ihm ausdrücklich
allen welche diese in der vergangenheit
ausgeführt habe
herr minister hallo glaube es nicht mehr
im hause ich danke ihnen persönlich
[Musik]
ich weiß ja nicht wo das herkommt herr
ministerpräsident entschuldigung für das
wort heuchler und scharlatan muss ich
hier einen ordnungsruf erteilen
gestatten sie eine zwischenfrage von
frau abgeordnete astrid rothe beinlich
herr minister mit ramelow ich danke
ihnen persönlich ganz besonders für
ihren einsatz für den freistaat
heute morgen haben sie uns in unserer
fraktionssitzung besucht es war ein
freundliches und konstruktives gespräch
sie haben ihre hand ausgestreckt für
eine konstruktive zusammenarbeit als
parlamentarier und nun lassen sie uns
auch sache orientiert für die zukunft
thüringen streiten als wir freie
demokraten im vergangenen oktober zur
landtagswahl angetreten sind hatten wir
das ziel das land positiv das land
thüringen positiv zu verändern und dem
parlament wieder eine liberale stimme zu
vergeben
bereits kurz nach der wahl wurde
deutlich dass die regierungsbildung im
freistaat nicht einfach werden würde und
dass man sich auf eine
minderheitsregierung einstellen muss
durch das wahlergebnis rückt das
parlament wieder stärker ins zentrum der
politischen willensbildung und das
bleibt es auch unser angebot lautete von
anfang an eine regierung aus der mitte
der gesellschaft aus der mitte des
parlaments heraus zu bilden und zu
diesem angebot stehen wir jetzt für uns
gilt was wir vor der wahl gesagt haben
gilt auch nach der wahl
das bedeutet auch dass die brandmauern
gegenüber den extremen stehen bleiben
bestehen und auch bestand haben
wer kemmerich gewählt hat hat ein
erbitterten gegner von allem gewählt was
auch nur einen hauch von radikalismus
rechts wie links faschismus aufweist
wir werden ein kompetentes und
vielfältiges und sachbezogen das
kabinett aufstellen wir sprechen eine
einladung an cdu spd und grüne aus
gemeinsam staatspolitische verantwortung
für thüringen wahrzunehmen
herr ministerpräsident der abgeordnete
adams hat eine zwischenfrage gestatten
sie dass man nein könnt ihr eure
kollegen mal sagen gemeinsam müssen wir
die besten lösungen für theorien in den
mittelpunkt der debatten stellen und zum
wohle des landes umsetzen
auch nach meiner heutigen wahl bleibt es
dabei dass du jede initiative im
parlament mehrheiten gefunden werden
müssen wir wollen dem freistaat
thüringen und seinen bürgerinnen und
bürgern die freiheit geben sich zu
entfalten und ihre potenziale zu nutzen
in der bildung in der wirtschaft in der
gesellschaft als ganzes für die fdp
fraktion beantrage ich abschließend die
siebte plenarsitzung zu vertagen
damit war's das auch schon mit der im
mittelfeld einen anderen
ministerpräsidenten aus der fdp-fraktion
die sitzung zu vertagen gibt es
widerspruch
dann lasse ich darüber abstimmen wer für
die vertagung der siebten
parlamentsberatung ist dem bitte ich um
das handzeichen
vielen dank
das sind alle stimmen aus der fdp
fraktion aus der cdu-fraktion und aus
der fdp-fraktion wer ist gegen die
vertagung
das sind stimmen aus der fraktion die
linke fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen und
spd enthält sich bei einer enthaltung
ist der antrag angenommen die sitzung
wird vortag damit schließe ich die
heutige beratung danke